given the attention right now on the
Nashville school shooting and on my
comments and response and on the hate
mob that has been sent at me by Don Jr
and Candace Owens and others I am again
going to take the opportunity to talk
about what doesn't work to reduce gun
violence in mass shootings and what does
now I want to contextualize this by
reminding you that you have
very uh uh sort of pathetic solutions
from the right which they don't even
actually believe in which we know
because they don't fund them I'll give
you an example they say say mass
shootings are really about mental health
well mental health might well be a
component but if you believe that you
should fund mental health treatment
services which they do not and in fact
in many states every time there's a
proposal to increase funding for exactly
those types of services they are against
funding it they don't want to do it we
say the problems mental health but we
won't do anything about it of course the
ubiquitous and ever-present thoughts and
prayers before thoughts and prayers and
after thoughts and prayers and thoughts
and prayers and thoughts and prayers and
the thoughts and prayers do nothing the
thoughts and prayers do nothing if
prayer is important to you in difficult
situations then by all means do it but
it is not policy to reduce gun violence
more recently now they are targeting
trans people drag shows gender affirming
care because of the trans identity of
the shooter in Nashville Tennessee give
me a break give me a break now if we
could somehow pass legislation if we
miraculously had the ability to get
build consensus and actually pass some
gun safety legislation
what would I do such that we would make
an impact I am going to give you the
disclaimer up front that I always do no
one of the bullet points I'm about to
list would prevent every mass shooting
not we have 340 million people in this
country
and every combination of mass shooting
no one rule would prevent every mass
shooting but taken together these 10
policies would significantly reduce the
number of mass shootings number one end
the Gun Show loophole The Gun Show
loophole is the fact that federal law
doesn't require unlicensed private
sellers to perform background checks on
gun purchasers you go and you buy a gun
at a dealer and they do the background
check great now if you make a private
sale you as an individual with no
license to sell firearms if you make a
private sale to someone else you are not
required by federal law to have that
buyer background checked some states
require it but there is no federal law
and as a result many states don't
require it would it solve every shooting
no but that is just obvious that should
be done number two Universal background
checks it would require almost all
firearms transactions in the United
States to go through the nics national
instant Criminal background check system
this is also part of closing the private
sale exemption so you've got the Gun
Show loophole and the private sale
exemption both are about getting around
background checks
um at least 22 States and DC require
background checks for Private Sales but
they are not required by federal law
number three mandatory waiting period
from when you go in and say I'd like a
gun please and when you get the gun
it won't prevent every shooting some
people some Shooters have guns that
they've had for years but for those who
are going and saying I want to do a
shooting let me go and get the gun and
you get it that day for some of them a
mandatory waiting period maybe it's five
days maybe it's ten days might actually
allow cooler heads to Prevail and might
reduce the number of these shootings
number four no high capacity weapons for
those under age 25 but David they could
get a handgun yes they could but in many
of these incidents not all but in many
of these incidents with a handgun rather
than an AR-15 the number dead would be
lower and fewer people dying is better
I'd rather zero but fewer is better
number five mandatory gun insurance
which is significantly more expensive
without apparent co-signing if you were
under 25 this is both a financial
disincentive which might just make the
entire thing more expensive particularly
for those under 25 remember when we look
at Mass Shooters overwhelmingly under
age 25. if you don't have a parent
saying yeah I think this makes sense and
we're going to get the insurance it is
dramatically more expensive number six
if you're under 25 and you want to get a
gun you should be required to provide
one maybe two Community Support letters
these would be letters from adults who
know you not your parents who say I am
fine with this individual having these
Firearms I have no issues with that and
if there are issues it doesn't mean any
random person in the community can say
no guns but it would require a more
scrutiny and maybe if someone goes and
tries to get a gun and a teacher and
whoever else says I have concerns about
this individual or if they're not even
able to find such individuals
then maybe that person shouldn't be able
to get guns number seven some weapons
should be banned there are simply there
are some weapons that are simply of no
recreational or any other value other
than as mass killing machines I'm not
pretending I have the exact list right
here in front of me people will disagree
about what should be on the list most
people think the shoulder mounted RPGs
should be not allowed most people
believe the handguns should be allowed
well now we're now we're negotiating now
we have to find what is the point there
are some weapons that should be banned
number eight there should be a periodic
mental health evaluation there should be
a mental health evaluation at the
beginning and there should be a mental
health evaluation periodically oh but
David that'll be expensive well it
should be paid by the licensing fees
which maybe are too low
that's another issue to discuss but
there should be a periodic mental health
evaluation you might be fine to have a
gun at 25 and then at 30 things have
changed and if you were subjected to a
mental health eval a mental health
professional might say you really
shouldn't have this gun
number nine the licensing process should
be more extensive you need a written and
a practical test for a driver's license
at minimum it should be the same for
guns the training and Licensing period
shouldn't be one weekend it should be
longer more like with cars where there
are hours of driver's ed and practical
uh
why not well because the right-wing gun
lobby has prevented it from being that
way and then number 10 there should be a
gun buyback program give people an
off-ramp that feels better than supposed
gun confiscation no one of these things
will stop every specific shooter someone
will write and they'll say David but
number nine wouldn't have stopped the
Uvaldi shoot
the point here is
we would stop some of the shootings
and we would be able to then say look at
the Improvement where can we tweak where
can we do more we have a second
amendment
none of these affect that
but we could be doing so much more but
none of this stuff will happen
with the current Republican party and
the NRA as powerful as it is
also
am I saying mental health isn't an issue
no the reason I want the mental health
evaluations is because I'm agreeing a
factor is mental health
there's also the cultural issue the
United States
is unique and many Americans don't
understand how weird it is to see
Firearms fetishized violence celebrated
intelligence condemned we need a
cultural change where people stop seeing
Firearms as the solutions to personal or
social problems I don't know how in hell
we do that that's a big issue in the
meantime though
10 policies all of which would prevent
some mass shootings so the thoughts and
prayers don't work I stand by that
here's 10 ideas that might and you know
what what do we have to lose we're not
fixing it do we've done nothing and it
hasn't solved the problem maybe it's
time to try something new